- What's up, y'all?
I'm back with Nico Santos, give it up!
(audience clapping and cheering)
So from time to time, it's really nice
to get out of the studio
and see people face to face
even if it's from a safe social distance.
So I've been hitting the road
to get to the outdoor theater
for what we call a
drive-interview. Get it?
♪ Drive interview ♪
Did you hear Jesse? Jesse with
the view, he was impressed.
(laughing)
The other day, I was hanging out
when the very funny Jesse
Tyler Ferguson pulled in.
I love that I'm just hanging
out randomly by myself
(chuckles)
and Jesse Tyler just happened to pull in.
It was so random, take a look.
(upbeat music)
- [Jesse] Come on, grandma.
- What's up. What's up?
How you doing, Jesse?
- I love it, I love the car.
- Um, I like your car.
- It's a, it's a model red.
- It's a model red?
- I don't know anything about cars.
(chuckling)
- You know, you don't like
classic cars or anything?
- I don't. And actually,
the closest I have
to any sort of like classic car
thing anywhere near my house
is this horse sculpture
that Justin and I bought
that's entirely made of
car parts and bike parts.
- Oh.
- That's the only thing that I have
in the classic car category in my house.
- (chuckles) That's funny.
Wait, speaking of houses,
you're in Gwyn's house.
- I am, yes.
- Yeah, you got Gwen Stefani's house.
- Yes. She lived there for,
I don't know like seven or eight years,
but yeah. It's got good
energy because of her.
- Oh, wow. Right on, right on.
Um, how is your little one?
Because, how old, how old now?
- [Jesse] He's seven months now.
- I was gonna say he
hasn't had a first birthday
because I did see the shower.
- [Jesse] Yes.
- The shower was incredible.
- In February, it was the last party
that anyone went to in the
world. It was our baby shower.
- That's kind of a cool one to go out on.
It was quite a blow out and
we didn't plan it ourselves.
We had a friend of ours plan it,
and the venue that they
rented had a swimming pool.
So we hired this group of
male synchronized swimmers
called um, the Aquawillies.
- W-w-w-what?
- Aquawillies, and they were amazing.
And they were, they were a
complete surprise to us, but...
- That's amazing.
How's it been, being a dad?
- It's been, it's been great. I love it.
- It's exhausting.
- It is so exhausting and the thing is
Beckett was born in July
and for like the first
three months, I was like
I'm so grateful to have this,
this time when I'm not working to just,
you know, spend time with him.
- Yeah.
And now I really, really, really wish
I could just like slip away
and go to work for the day.
- Yeah.
- Julie, Julie Bowen and Ty
Burrell would always like,
stay in their trailer
a little while longer
after they were done shooting
and just like get naps in.
And I have no, I can't do that.
I can't just disappear
and take a nap somewhere.
- You will, you will get there.
(laughing)
- I'm just gonna lie down.
- You will totally get there and be like,
man it was so weird,
work went a little longer than suspected.
- [Jesse] Yeah, yeah.
Meanwhile, you're just
sitting in your car.
- They're like, how was the
chat with Kelly Clarkson,
you were, you were there a long time.
I'm like sleeping in
the back of this thing.
- Well, I'm chatty. You can
blame it on that. I talk a lot.
(chuckles)
I found this amazing.
So, you came out with a cookbook, right?
- Yeah. I have a cooking partner.
Her name is Julie Tanous.
She and I met at a dinner
party like six years ago.
She has taught me how to
do so much in the kitchen.
And so, we, we wrote a cookbook together
and it's um, we've been working
on it for like two years.
It's called Food Between Friends.
- What a great title.
- Yeah. It's been really fun. Yeah.
- So, you love food. You're a foodie.
So, how is your little one, Beckett?
How is he with food?
- [Jesse] He's, he's
actually a little picky, um,
which is concerning to me.
- Welcome to having a boy.
- [Jesse] Yeah. (chuckles)
- Because my girl will eat anything,
I could bribe her to eat anything.
And, my boy eats anything beige.
- Ours is a, if it's a tiniest little,
if it has the tiniest little
bit of flavor, he's like, no.
- Yeah, and he freaks out.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] Have you ever
gone too spicy with food?
Have you ever been making
something and you...
- I mean, I, I love Mexican food and I,
I have gone too spicy with that actually.
And it, it happened with my older age.
I'm 45 now, and like five years ago,
I remember lying in bed like,
Oh my God, I think I'm
having a heart attack.
And I actually went to the hospital
and it was just acid reflux.
I'm like, oh, that's
something I have to deal with.
(audience laughing)
- Did you feel like such a tool?
- I felt like such an idiot.
They're like, you're just a little gassy.
- They're like, so you have heartburn.
- [Jesse] Yeah.
(laughs) So embarrassing.
They like prescribed me Tums.
- It's life threatening, help me.
(laughs)
That was amazing.
Well, I love seeing you.
- [Jesse] It's so good to see you.
- And I loved hanging out with you.
- Before, I leave though, you um,
I know you work with Blake.
I do actually have some
of Gwen's, um, mail.
I'm still getting at the
house, catalogs and stuff.
- Oh, yeah.
- So, I don't know if like,
- Oh, that's a box, it's a box.
Yeah.
Oh.
- [Jesse] Bring that over to her.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
That's a box of stuff. Okay.
- So good to see you.
- It's nice to see you.
I will get that to them.
(car honks)
(upbeat music)
- [Jesse] Bye.
(audience cheers and claps)
- Aren't, wait, what about you?
Do you like cooking at home?
- Uh, yeah, I've done nothing
but cook during quarantine
which is why I've gained like, 700 pounds.
(laughs)
- Honestly, I gained
because I didn't cook.
I Postmated a lot. (chuckles)
- Well, that too. We would
cook and then Postmates
and the cycle continues.
- Do you like cooking?
- I love cooking.
I, my boyfriend is the savory
cook and I'm more of a baker.
- [Kelly] Oh, what a team.
- I know, it's great. It's great. (laughs)
- I'm just alone. Just
cooking for me, so. (laughs)
Just kidding, no,
I, it doesn't matter if
people are there or not.
I can't cook.
Um, don't forget to
pick up Jesse's new book
Food Between Friends.